[Music]
the earth might not be here forever a
huge solar flare an asteroid impact or a
local gamma-ray burst anything could
wipe us out for good if we're looking
for some place to escape to
there is one planet in our solar system
that's somewhat similar to Earth though
we don't know much about it
no it's not Mars its Venus
not only our earth and Venus about the
same size they both have identical
interiors with partially liquid cores
mantels and crusts yet Venus happens to
be the most hostile terrestrial planet
in the solar system but what if I told
you that you could explore this hot
planet without ever setting foot on it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we built cloud cities on Venus
Venus is in a place you'd want to land
on thanks to its dense atmosphere and
turtle-like rotation the surface
temperature of Venus stays at 462
degrees the planet's atmospheric
pressure is 92 times greater than
Earth's because of such high pressure
anything entering the atmosphere of
Venus gets immediately crushed before it
reaches the planets volcanic surface
with such extreme atmospheric conditions
it's too dangerous to attempt a man's
landing on Venus but we wouldn't need to
go down there above the dense layer of
clouds Venus isn't that bad the
atmospheric pressure is similar to
Earth's the gravity is slightly lower
and the temperature reaches 75 degrees
although that's a little hot it's still
workable now how would we get there well
we'd need to start small according to
NASA's plan for exploring Venus we'd
send two spaceships to our destination
venus is the closest planet to earth
that's why it would only take 100 days
for the craft to arrive there one of the
ships would be run by robots it would
carry a special airship that would eject
into the atmosphere upon arrival this
airship would start to inflate itself
with helium and since helium is lighter
than air the airship would float
orbiting about 52 kilometers above the
planet
the second spaceship would have a crew
of two people it would link up with the
airship orbiting Venus the crew would
have 30 days to make all the
environmental assessments after that
they detach from the airship and start
making their way back to earth the
return trip would take about 300 days
due to the sun's strong gravitational
pull but even with that the complete
mission wouldn't take longer than 450
days after analyzing the information
from the first mission we begin to plan
our next trip to Venus but this time
we'd stay there longer the next crew
would have a year to study the planet
and its atmosphere
one of the things they'd be looking for
on Venus would be life scientists think
that because microbes on earth can
thrive in acidic conditions surrounded
by sulfur there could be life found in
the Venusian atmosphere after the end of
the second mission we would start
preparing to stay on Venus permanently
we would begin building cloud cities
where future generations of humans would
live and hopefully continue to explore
space and the origins of life in it they
might even solve the pressure problem
from there they would terraform the
planet and settle down on the once
hostile Venusian surface but that's a
story for another what if